So, today we're going to talk about
data.
And where we are is that
you know how to train a model
given data.
Last time we saw evaluation, so we know
what a good model is.
And the for the next two lectures this
week we're going to focus on what data
should we train on.
And I want to argue that data is the
most important thing to get right in
language models. And one justification
for this is if you look at what
companies actually disclose. So, here is
the Llama 3 paper.
Um they have full transparency into
architecture. Well, of course, because
it's open weight model.
Um they even tell you about the training
procedures.
Um but they don't say anything about
their data.
So, they just say we train from a
variety of data sources.
Um and do some stuff.
And there's good reasons for this
secrecy.
One is that um data is is kind of your
competitive secret sauce, uh competitive
dynamics. You don't want to let your
competitors what you're doing.
And the second thing, which we'll talk a
little bit more about, is is copyright
liability. You don't want to get sued if
you tell people you're training on
certain types of data.
So,
data is a long topic in in machine
learning. And before foundation models,
data working meant you annotate label
data for supervised learning.
Um nowadays there's less um manual
annotation, at least in pre-training.
But there's still a lot of curation and
cleaning work that needs to be done. And
so, fundamentally this hasn't really
changed. Data has always been a
bottleneck and always will be a
bottleneck because it's in some sense of
long-tail problem.
And that scales with human effort. So,
if you have a lot of people trying to
work on a problem, well, there's only so
many people that can work on
architectures and systems, but data,
well, that's like, you know, especially
if you're training a foundation model
that's trying to do all these things,
you can paralyze that effort easily. So,
that's why these data teams and
these model developers are actually
quite quite big.
So,
so data comes in at different stages of
a of the pipeline. Today, we're focusing
mostly on pre-training.
So, pre-training, you take raw data,
these are documents from the web, then
you move into mid-training where you
train on more high-quality data to
enhance certain capabilities and give
long context, things like that. And then
finally, post-training where you're
training on things like
chat transcripts or
if you're doing reinforcement learning,
you get some environments that you're
training on. This becomes more
task-specific.
In practice, the lines are a bit blurry.
Um
and there could be more than three
stages,
but this is sort of a basic template. Um
the trend is that we go from training on
large amounts of low-quality data to
smaller amounts of high-quality data.
So, as a result of this process, you'll
see in the literature some people talk
about a base model. This usually means
after pre-training and mid-training.
Instruct models or chat models are after
post-training.
Um but of course, the lines are becoming
blurry enough that what is a base model
anymore is really kind of unclear and
more recently,
the largest models are there's no base
model. There's just Qwen 3.5 397B and
that's it. There's you don't see the
intermediate checkpoints.
So, for models that are open source,
like Olmo from AI2, you can see
everything that's happening. And so,
we'll study some of these models. Um so
for example, in pre-training, there's a
bunch of sources, which we'll talk about
what these mean, but you know, some web
pages, academic papers, math pages,
proofs, and so on. There's mid-training.
Um higher-quality web data, instruction
data,
um a bunch of synthetic data often goes
here.
And then finally, post-training, there
is a bunch of um you know, chat uh logs.
There's more math and reasoning and
coding and and you do safety at this at
this point as well.
So, you know, what are all these data
sets?
You know, how do you choose them, and
how do you process them?
So, that's that's the main question.
Okay, so in the spirit of the class,
we're going to talk about data. I'm
going to go start from scratch. So,
where does data come from?
Okay, so
um
you know, one might hear in
the hallway, "Oh, language models are
trained on the entire internet."
So, so first of all, this doesn't really
quite type check because for that to be
true, it would have to be an agent that
like an RL agent that goes on the
internet and like does stuff, but that's
not actually how pre-training works. Um
slightly more accurately, it's trained
on the public World Wide Web. Um this is
not quite accurate uh for reasons I'll
explain.
Okay, so first of all, the web is
actually uh a bunch bunch of live
servers that just exist in the world,
and you can connect to. So, take any
website, you can go and download a page.
Or you can basically send a request and
get back a response.
So, you can't actually train on these
live uh servers unless you're training
an RL agent. Um so typically, what you
do is you you have a crawler, or someone
builds a crawler, not necessarily you.
Um the crawler
needs to discover what web pages are out
there, starting with a seed seed set,
and it downloads this discovered web
pages as it's it's crawling.
So, um
but now
still you can't just run a crawl and
download all the web pages on the
internet.
And there's a few reasons for this. Um
one is that a lot of the web content is
actually dynamic. So, especially these
days a lot of sites are apps.
Um the URL isn't even as full a
specification of the content. It's just
um an app that you interact with. Um and
you need to often click buttons or
submit forms to access content.
Um for example, if you're on, you know,
Discord or something, it's not like you
can just like
crawl Discord and get a um all the
content out of Discord.
Okay? So, so that's one kind of thing,
and a lot of content is actually known
as kind of in the deep web, um which is
not just like you're, you know, doing um
uh web page crawling and following
hyperlinks, which is a very kind of
traditional model of web crawling.
The second thing is that um
you know, authentication. So, some pages
need a login and account, and generally
you have to
to pay.
Um for example, there's Facebook, X,
LinkedIn, New York Times.
Um there's actually huge amounts of
content that are actually locked up
behind these walled gardens. So, these
are technically on the internet or on
the web, but uh you can't just build a
crawler and go crawl uh you know,
Facebook.
I guess if you're Facebook, you can
crawl Wait, you don't need to crawl
Facebook. You have the data and you can
train a model. Or if you're you're X
XAI, you can train on X. But if you're
anyone else, you can't actually access
this content.
So, okay, suppose you don't have the
authentication issue, there's still
potential restrictions here.
Um so,
so there's something called robots.txt.
And this is a file that um is usually
placed at the root level of
a directory such such as nytimes.com.
And it basically tells you what you're
allowed to crawl and what not. So, this
things are a lot of things are
disallowed such as uh OAI search bot or
perplexity bot, Cora bot.
Um, I think basically
uh chat GPT user, Claude bot, and all
these things.
Okay? So, um this is not a
tech This is not a legal restriction.
This is just like you're supposed to be
a good citizen and look at robots.txt.
And if your name is on that list, then
you should not crawl. That's That's
basically the
um the contract not even a contract.
That That is the
thing you're supposed to do.
Um
A lot of websites now use
um something like Cloudflare to detect
and block bot activity.
So, sometimes you go on to a website and
it gives you a capture, right? That's
because it's somehow some algorithm has
detected that you might be a bot and
then it's making sure you're human.
And um if you're actually a bot there
then well, you can't I mean, you could
try to get around this, but it generally
this is a obstacle in your way.
A website might block certain IP
addresses um or or countries and they
might have rate limits. So, there's
technical restrictions on what you can
actually uh crawl.
Um
And then there's also legal
restrictions.
So,
um there's websites have terms of
service that say, "If you go to a
website, you have to obey this contract
to use the website." And the terms of
service often will say, "If you are a
bot, go away." Um, "You cannot use this
the content of the site for AI training
or
um whatever it might be."
And um
And also, if the if you even if terms of
service don't say anything, the content
of the website might have, you know, a
license uh or you might not have a
license to train. And we'll talk more
about this in a bit.
So, there's legal restrictions on what
you can uh allowed to train on.
These things are also evolving over
time. Um so, there's a nice paper um by
Shane Lampray called uh Consent Consent
in Crisis.
And what they did is they examined the
restrictions, both the technical
restrictions, robots.txt, and the legal
restrictions, the terms of service,
um for various URLs in common data sets
which we'll talk about later.
And the conclusion was that the
restrictions have increased over time.
So, here's a graphic that shows The top
one shows robots.txt.
Um and if you just look at this red,
that's the full restrictions. Um and up
until 2023,
um everything was fairly fairly
constant. And then up until 20 mid-2023,
all of a sudden you see the amount of
the fraction of websites that have full
restrictions on it has grown to almost
like, you know, 50% here.
And for terms,
um this there's a similar trend where
I guess um in 2016, no one really put
any terms on their pages, and now most
pages put some terms, and um
most of the terms say uh you can't uh
use this for AI.
Okay, so even though it was possible to
crawl the internet back
uh in, you know, let's say 20 2020,
the internet actually, at least what you
can legally uh crawl is actually much
smaller.
So,
of course, these are
you know, guidelines and sometimes
either intentionally or unintentionally
you could violate these things. So, this
is sometimes you get into these
situations where
there's this guy who
um
uh what was this I forget the name of
this the site was complaining about
Anthropic crawling them hitting their
servers a million times in 24 hours
which was
not good. And then read the docs was
also getting hammered. So, there's a
period where which I think probably has
hopefully been corrected by now that
crawlers were
hammering you know, websites. And and
there the here this is interesting is
like even before talking about copyright
issues. There's I think problems with
crawling because
either violating terms of service or
robots.txt
or just just blow up down
you know, generating a lot of server
load which this costs money for the
person hosting it and also degrade
service for everyone else trying to use
it. So, there are you know, issues with
with crawling and then of course there's
copyright which will talk about soon.
That's a whole another complex can of
worms.
Okay, and then finally there's these
things called shadow libraries there
which are also part of the web.
Um so, examples are
Libgen or Anna's Archive
and these they completely disregard
copyright and bypass paywalls. So,
someone has collected a ton of of data
usually books and articles that are all
copyright and people have to pay for
these and have made them available for
free.
Um and these there have been a lot of
takedown orders, lawsuits and these are
blocked but Um, these are circumvented
because
um, they just make servers in other
countries.
Um, and the people doing this
argue that this is making free what's
freely available, what should have been
freed. But, generally from a legal
perspective, this is piracy and
copyright infringement. And we'll come
back to this point later. So, there are
a lot of books and papers on this uh on
these uh shadow libraries.
Okay, so the summary so far,
the internet is a huge and messy and you
know, scary place.
Um, and
you can't actually get all of it. Um,
there are technical restrictions,
there's legal restrictions on what um
data one can access. So, now it's next
time someone says uh I trained on the
internet, you can tell them all of these
things you uh learned.
Okay, so now let's go to the the second
uh part of
you know, what data can we use? Um,
and this has to do with uh copyright.
So, suppose you were able to obey the
terms of service
um and you are really a good citizen and
you obey the rate limits.
Um, now there's still a question of are
you allowed to train on this data?
And this is a ongoing uh
question that has not been fully
resolved, but there has been a bunch of
developments in the last uh year.
So, the legal uh context for thinking
about this question falls into
intellectual property law.
And this is a system of you know, system
that is trying to incentivize the
creation of intellectual goods. So, I
think it's remember to
uh remember the spirit of the law is to
not just say,
you know, technically say no to
everything, but to incentivize the
creation of uh intellectual goods.
And there's many forms of intellectual
property that are covered.
There's copyrights, patents, trademarks
trademarks and secrets. Trade trademarks
and trade secrets.
The thing that has is most relevant for
language model data is copyright law.
So copyright law has a fairly long
history going back to the 1700s in
England.
And so 1709 was the first time that
governments and courts started actually
regulating a copyright for this goal of
incentivizing you know innovation and
creation.
And in the US more recently the
Copyright Act of 1976 is what think of
defines a lot of kind of modern
copyright. So copyright protection
applies to original works of authorship
authorship fixed in any tangible medium
of expression. Yada yada yada.
Okay?
So
a few notes. So not everything is
copyrightable.
In particular
collections are not copyrightable. So
for example, if you have a a telephone
you know directory
unless there is some creativity in how
you arrange things,
this is not really a copyrightable.
And furthermore copyright applies to an
expression not the idea.
So you can't copyright an an idea like
you can't copyright the quicksort
algorithm. You can copyright the like
implementation of a quicksort algorithm,
but not the quicksort algorithm.
So one thing that happened in 1976
is that the barrier to getting a
copyright was relaxed a lot. So more
things are copyright. So it used to be
that you had to publish something to
have something copyright. Now um,
just have to be fixed. And what that
means is that
registration of any sort is not required
for copyright protection. This is in
contrast to patents. Patents, you have
to go pay a a lot of money to get a
patent and you would have to file a
patent. But, the threshold for copyright
is very low. For example, you put
something on your website, it's
copyrighted.
That's it.
Um, now,
you if you want to sue someone, you have
to go get it registered, but it only
costs $65. So, um, which is much smaller
than the lawyer fees that you'll
probably pay. So, um, it's really still
a very low low bar.
So, one thing to know about copyright is
that it lasts,
uh,
75 years and then the copyright expires
and whatever that content gets released
into the public domain and this is now
you permiss- everyone can use it freely.
Okay, so a lot of, um, people who have,
uh, lived in the past, um, all of their
great works are in the public domain,
which is great for everyone.
So, the rationale here is that you're
incentivizing innovation.
Um, so,
when an artist or a creator creates
something, you want to protect their You
don't want to have someone else to just
take it. So, you protect them for a
while, but, you know, after 75 years,
presumably, it's not worth protecting or
they're passed away or something. So, it
doesn't make sense to keep things, uh,
copyrighted anymore.
Okay, so So, basically, everything on
the internet is, uh,
copyrighted.
Okay, so you're saying, "Hm, wait a
minute. So, that means is every
everything just if I train on anything,
that's a copyright violation?" Well,
not necessarily.
So, everything is copyrighted, but you
can use copyrighted works. And the way
you do it is
A, you either get a license for it
or B, you appeal to appeal to the fair
use clause.
Okay, so a license is
from contract law is something that a
licensor grants to a licensee. Basically
says, don't sue me.
Like you can uh
you can use this this work in the ways
that the license permits.
So there's a really nice license called
you know creative commons
which allows something to kind of act
like it was in the public domain. Um
enables free distribution of copyrighted
work. So your examples include like
Wikipedia, OpenCourseWare, Khan Academy,
um all these all these things. It was
created in 2001
to essentially bridge public domain and
existing copyright because
otherwise you have to wait 75 years. But
what if the creator says, I don't I will
actually want people to use it. They can
now have a means a legal means of
saying, I put a creative commons license
on it. It's going to act like it's in
the public domain and uh
you know, and everyone can use it.
So so far things in the public domain
and things that have creative commons
licenses are uh
uh you can use it.
Um but there's many other things that
uh
times where you don't have it's not a
creative commons license, it's not in
the public domain. You have to get a
license. So
um
if you have money, you can pay someone
uh to give you a license. So there's a
bunch of deals between model developers
and content uh I guess platforms that uh
license allow the model developers to
license the data for training foundation
models.
Okay, so that's the first thing. You can
get a license, either Creative Commons
or you can pay someone for a license.
Now, if you don't want to pay,
you can appeal to fair use,
which is a more complicated matter.
Um so, this is section 107 of the
Copyright Act. And there are
basically, fair use says, I can use this
anyway, even if I don't have a license.
And there's four factors determine
whether four fair use applies.
So, the first one is the purpose or
character of the use, like what are you
trying to do with it?
And none of these are, you know,
hard rules. They're just tendencies
which have to be weighed in in court if
it comes to that.
So, for example, if you're trying to do
something for education, it is more
likely to be fair use than if you're
trying to sell and make money off of it.
If you're trying to if you transform
something, then that's going to be more
favored than if you just literally host
the identical copy.
Um the nature of the actual copyrighted
work is also important. So, things that
are more factual are more likely to be
fair use than fictional works. Right?
Because if you write a summary of World
War,
you know, facts about page about facts
about World War II is is less There's
less um
protection over a
you know, my
you know, really creative poem.
Um
And then
uh
you know, the amount of portion of the
original work. So, using a snippet is uh
favored over the whole work. So, if you
just take a little bit, that's not as
bad as taking everything. So, that's
fairly straightforward.
And the final thing is um
is kind of related to original
motivation. It was like, why do you why
copyright at all? It's to protect uh and
align economic incentives. So, the
effect that um what the the use has on
the market for the original work. So, if
you take author's work and you provide
an alternative and that decreases amount
that the original author could
monetize their work, that is seen as
potentially bad. But, if you're
transforming in a way and adding, you
know, going to a new market or doing
something else with it, then that's
going to be treated more favorably.
Okay. So, here's some examples of fair
use. You can watch a movie and write a
summary of it. You can reimplement an
an idea like an algorithm,
not copy the code.
And then there was this
famous
you know lawsuit between Authors Guild
and Google.
So, if you go to Google Books, you can
see snippets of of various books, which
are copyright.
So, there was a huge um
uh you know
uh
deal about whether this was deemed fair
use because you're sort of
redistributing
um
you know, other copyrighted work. And
and eventually
eventually meaning after 11 years, this
lawsuit was settled in favor of Google,
which is why this thing exists.
And this has set some precedent for
thinking about
whether
you know language model training is fair
use.
Um one thing to note is that copyright
is is not about verbatim memorization.
So, this might be I think for ML
audience, this might be a little bit new
because a lot of papers are focused on
verbatim memorization, but that's that's
one way you can violate copyright, but
not the only one. So, for example,
plots and characters can be
copyrightable.
So, you can copyright Harry Potter, the
the character, not any particular
um
you know, book or anything.
But, uh there are some exceptions. For
example, if you're parodying something,
uh so, you're creating something that is
looks like a derivative, but as long as
you're making fun of it, it's actually
more likely to be fair use.
So, this Yeah. So, a lot of copyright is
about semantics. It's definitely not
about n-gram overlap. Um
and also about uh
the economics.
Okay. So, what is the implication for
language models?
So,
first off, um
copying data,
like even if you're not training, like
even the mere fact of copying,
which is in the word copyright, is
potentially a violation already, even if
you don't do anything with it.
Okay?
Um
training a model, um
you know, I guess this is
This is not really a Let's see how I
would have to take that. This is not
necessarily a a fact, but is intuitively
has a transformative uh flavor, right?
Because it certainly not It certainly
seems different than just like
re-hosting uh another work, right? It's
doing something uh transformative.
Um
and
you know, in some sense, the models are
really trained on this data as a means
to the end. You know, we're trying to
extract the general idea, learn about
the world and how it works, rather than
only just the uh concrete expression.
Um and the other thing is that
regardless of cop- copyright, language
models can definitely affect um
you know, the market. So, so I think
this is also, remember, that's the
fourth uh item for for fair use. So, by
negatively affecting the market, you're
you know, more likely to be ruled um not
fair use.
Okay, so so fair use is kind of a little
bit, you know, slippery. Um
Um suppose you have fair use or you have
a license,
um remember that there's still terms of
service that allow prevent you from
actually just uh getting a piece of
work. For example, YouTube has all these
videos which are
um
licensed.
But the terms of service
um forbid prohibits just downloading the
videos uh as a using a bot or like
scraping.
Right? So, which is another layer. So,
there's multiple layers of
um restrictions here.
Okay, so let me talk a little bit about
where things are on the legal landscape.
So, back in 2023, New York Times filed
suit against OpenAI saying, "You trained
on our news articles and look, here's
evidence we were able to actually prompt
uh ChatGPT to generate a news article
almost verbatim."
Uh I don't think this is this is still
pending. There's uh a case against
Anthropic where
um the allegation was you pirated
millions of books and you trained on
these books to to make Claude.
Um just last year
uh this was a kind of a landmark ruling
um that said, "Actually, this particular
instance of training is is fair use.
However,
Anthropic, you're still in trouble
because you pirated all these books
um and that is a no-no.
Right? So, notice that this is has
nothing to do with training.
Just a mere a fact of cop- pirating, I
mean, which is this is not a a new
thing, is is is um illegal.
Um Anthropic, actually, interestingly,
had bought and scanned all of the books,
um which is actually fair use. So, the
court said, "You're allowed to scan. You
buy a bunch of books, rip off the
binding, scan and digitize it for your
own use. That's fair use."
But, that doesn't absolve you of your
sin of uh pirating. So, you can't pirate
and then buy it and say like, "Actually,
never mind what I just uh did first."
Um so, the outcome is that Anthropic
paid 1.5 billion to settle um the
authors. So, this is like about $3,000 a
book.
Um so, there's also a lawsuit against
Meta.
Um
The allegation was that you trained on
our books. Um sorry.
And uh this was, as we'll see later,
actually revealed in the the Llama
paper. And the judgment, which came
right after Anthropic, was um yes,
training is fair use.
Um and then they also torrented some
books, so that's still pending. So,
that's probably
um if precedent holds, this is also not
going to be uh good for for Meta.
Um
Okay, so the summary so far
is um
training,
you know, so to speak, has been deemed
uh fair use or at least has been not
deemed not fair use.
Um
The new rulings have so far been,
you know, narrow. It's not to say that
any training on any copyrighted content
is is fair use.
Um but in these cases, it's fine. Uh
pirating books is clearly illegal. I
guess we already knew that.
And but this is still a very active and
evolving uh area.
Okay, any questions about the the
sources of data?
I think before we get into the actual
data sets, I just want to
kind of
um set the stage with this kind of a
more general uh social context.
Yeah.
Um the question is what do I think of
voice dating at 11 labs?
Um I don't know too much about that, so
um
so we can talk offline.
Yeah.
>> [clears throat]
>> Yeah, so the question is what happens
with time if you have one license and
then it gets changed, uh what happens?
So, first I'm not a lawyer.
Um however, uh second, so this
um
so the first license, I believe you're
still allowed to train on it, but what
happens is that the license usually
applies to not just let's say a fixed
set of documents, for example, Reddit.
There's constantly new content being
created
um and the license being changed means
that you wouldn't be able to train on
the the later
things.
Um
Okay, so let's look at various uh
sources of uh data.
So, let's go back to crawling.
Um so most model developers um have
their own crawler uh because they want
to have control over full control over
what the data
is. Um
Um fortunately for the rest of us, if
you don't want to uh build your own
crawler, um there's something called
Common Crawl, which has been around for
quite some time since 2007.
Um,
and every month they run a web crawl.
Uh, gets about 3 to 5 billion web pages.
Um, each crawl has some overlap with a
previous crawl, but they try to
diversify and get new pages. Um, so
there's 300 billion pages so far.
Um, which seems This was from their
website. It seems a little bit big
because if you multiply this number by
20, um, you don't really get a 300
billion, but that's what they say.
Um,
so how many URLs are out there? That's
really hard to estimate. So, uh, the
Google search index is at least 100
petabytes, uh, according to them.
And
um, you know, each Common Crawl,
uh,
dump has about two, uh, billion, you
know, web pages. So, that's about 372,
um, terabytes.
And this is not including images. This
is just mostly focused on the, um, the
text.
So, crawling is is conceptually
straightforward, but all the, uh, gory
details are in the implementation. You
start with a bunch of URLs,
um, and then you you iterate. It's
basically graph traversal. You pop a URL
from a queue, you download it, and then
you look at all the hyperlinks in that
page, and then you add them to the
queue. And generally this is done in
parallel, uh, over many machines.
Um, and uh, there's many decisions here.
Which paper, which pages to download.
Um,
to respect You have to respect our
robots.txt.
Don't overload the server. Um,
sometimes, uh, the websites change, and
so you want a policy that will download,
um,
you know, frequently change pages, but
not spend time downloading pages that
don't change. So, there's some policy
around that. And like I mentioned
before, URLs are dynamic, so
um
both sometimes the same URL leads to
different content depending on like some
state of the the browser, but also
different many URLs might lead to the
same content, so there's a lot of
duplication that um happens if you're
not you know, careful.
Um in particular, mirror sites um
explicitly is about duplication.
So, Common Crawl releases their dumps in
two formats. One is a WARC uh file. So,
this is the raw HTTP response.
Right? So, this remember HTTP protocol
is that you send a a get
you know, here's a a a URL uh
and then out comes a a HTTP kind of
response. And it's just the WARC file is
that response.
Um
they also do some processing, they
convert to a WAT file, uh which is
necessarily a lossy process.
Um it turns out that this is not
necessarily the best way to use uh the
web. Um
the HTML to text
uh there are many tools for this,
including Trafilatura and Brazilia
Parser. And the way you convert actually
does matter. So, this is from the Data
Comp at WLM paper, which we'll talk a
little about. It is ablation, where you
look at the WAT files that Common Crawl
releases versus these other
um
these other tools. And it seems like
Trafilatura and Brazilia Parser are um
you know, better.
Okay, so
one thing you can do is just rely on
general web crawls.
But often, the the web is not a uniform
place. It's not like you there's uh a
bunch of websites and you just like get
some random fraction of them and that's
your data set. And there are specific
pockets of really interesting high
quality content, and I'll talk about
three of those, Wikipedia, GitHub, and
archive. So, Wikipedia, all of you know
about
um
it's been around since 2001, and now
there's
67 million articles of around all these
different languages.
Um
and it is it doesn't Wikipedia is not
all
um content by any means. There's no You
can't have original thought
um in it
because everything has to be kind of
referenced and cited.
So, in some sense, you could argue that
Wikipedia is doesn't contain anything
because that's not already on on the on
the web. Well, actually, that's not true
because
they can also cite books, which are, you
know, obviously, you can't easily get
them. So, Wikipedia is so good. Um
So,
and also there's articles based on
notability.
So, not everything
Not everyone
can get a Wikipedia article about them.
Um
So, anyone on the internet can write
this content. This was the radical thing
about wikis,
and it's sort of still a miracle, I
think, to me that this this actually
works.
It just happens that any vandalisms gets
reverted by administrators or bots, I
guess, these days.
There's um
you know, a small number of Wikipedians,
like as any sort of peer production
system, there's a small set of people
who do most of the work.
Um
And for example, this guy has like 5
million edits. Um
and
one thing about Wikipedia is that every
few weeks they do a periodic dump. So,
basically, take all Wikipedia, package
into a nice
um tar file, and then you can just
download that.
So, this is important because you don't
need to crawl Wikipedia. In fact, they
don't want you to crawl Wikipedia. They
just want you to download this if you're
going to crawl. And this is much uh
better than crawling.
One kind of just a fun aside or um good
to know is that there's this paper um
that says
um you can actually poison uh Wikipedia.
So, you might think that this vandalism
um gets reverted. So, if you do attacker
tries to do something fishy uh you'll
just get it rolled back. But, what um
Carlini uh realized is that these
periodic dumps um happen at a regular
cadence.
And so, what what you can do is you can
go in and you can just edit it right
before the dump happens.
And then the dump ha- the it happens and
then um and then the edits get rolled
back, but the dump still has the
malicious content.
Um
and with if you're able to inject things
into uh web pages, that means you can
cause there's works that's uh show that
you can cause um
the model to, let's say, ascribe
negative sentiment to any sort of uh
trigger uh phrase like the iPhone.
So, my one takeaway here is that um if
you can consider adversaries, even
so-called high-quality contents might
contain um bad things in them.
I think this has been uh a fix uh since
then.
Okay, so GitHub is a good place for code
and code is important um not just for if
you want coding capabilities for your
language model, but if you want general
um you know, reasoning. Um so, GitHub,
all of you know
um again, it's a live service for
hosting code repositories. Uh been
around for since 2008, about the same
age as uh Common Crawl.
Um it has 400
uh 20 million repositories, 28 million
are public. Um, each repository contains
an It's not a file. It's as you know,
it's it's a directory with commit
history, issues, pull requests, and
comments.
Um, code has generally a lot of um, you
know, duplicates um, and this because
either copying code or or forking code.
Um,
and um, GitHub has deemed it you're
allowed to train on any public
repository with a permissive uh, you
know, license. So, MIT or Apache
licenses are are fine.
Um, so you there's uh remember there's
two types of data when you talk about
GitHub. There's like the repository data
which you can uh just uh go and download
through the GitHub Git protocol. And
again, you know, you shouldn't scrape
GitHub. Uh you should just download the
repository. And then the metadata
associated with each repository, issues,
and pull requests, and so on. These are
made actually via the GitHub archive
which gives you hourly snapshots of this
event stream, which I think is interest-
really interesting data. It's basically
every single comment or star or um
action on GitHub gets uh
that gets recorded.
There's this uh Software Heritage
Foundation that um
is focused on the repository, not the
metadata. And they aggregate GitHub um
GitHub is not the only place where code
shows up. There's also smaller um
entities like GitLab, Bitbucket, and so
on. And they aggregate all that those
repositories.
Um,
okay, so archive uh just very briefly,
everyone knows archive. This has been
around as a site that allows people to
share papers since 1991, started with
physics, and now has a lot of uh other
areas in it. Um,
each uh of the 3 million submissions has
the metadata, a PDF, and optional LaTeX
source.
Okay, so already you should be thinking,
well, what does it mean to train on
archive? It's uh not clear because this
is well, you have to convert the PDF
into a text or you can use a LaTeX
source, which is a bunch of files. Um
there it's not peer-reviewed, but there
is some approval process, and authors
can choose to maintain the rights uh or
put in the Creative Commons, which uh so
everything is actually very clearly
licensed. Um all the metadata is under
permissive license, so you can use that
regardless, and then you can go and you
look at all the papers that are Creative
Commons licensed, you download those,
and you can use them.
And I think most archive papers are
uh Creative uh you know, Commons.
Um
and then again, this is available, you
don't crawl archive, you just go down to
uh bulk download it from some uh
website.
Okay.
So, any questions about um source of
data? Yeah.
Are there restrictions on data generated
by models?
Generated by models? Yeah, by using that
data.
Oh, oh, I see. Uh we'll talk about that
uh later on. So, the question is, what
about model generated, like synthetic
data, are you allowed to use it?
Um the short answer is probably yes.
Yeah. Are you using crawlers like Open
or crawl and stuff like that? Um
I guess like the
cuz you mentioned earlier that there are
websites that have a lot of pirated
books on it, right? How do you like How
do you ensure that those types of
websites don't show up in your crawl of
the internet. Yeah.
Yeah, so the question is there's a lot
of websites with pirated books. So, if
you're just doing a web crawl, you can't
look at all the websites. So, how do you
make sure that everything is kosher? And
that's part of the difficulty is you
can't.
And and so
there's most likely in Common Crawl
there are copyrighted books and content
that
uh you are not supposed to
train on and you can appeal to you
appeal Well, you appeal to fear it. So,
remember everything is copyright. Books
are not
uh remarkably different from your your
website.
Uh for example, both are uh you know,
copyrighted. Probably a book author has
more of a
uh
you know, if they want to go into court,
they'll probably be able to protect that
better because it's published than your
uh your website, but
um but but still. Um
and I'll talk a little little bit about
later. If you really want to be careful,
um you can do something I'll um
show later.
Okay, so what I'm going to do now is to
now talk about the various uh
data sets that are actually used in
building models starting all the way
back to 2019. So, we've talked about the
origin of data and source of data. So,
you have a feeling for just the general
um data you know, landscape. Um
and so let's start with BERT. Okay, so
BERT was from 20
um 18 and they trained back in the day,
they just trained on Wikipedia and
books. So, what is this books?
Um
so, there's this website called
Smashwords. It was uh created that allow
anyone to just put a ebook uh up for to
publish and they had about half a
million books in 2024. So, in 2015 there
is this paper
um
who just scraped uh
Smashwords. Um uh so sorry, took the
books that were free
and um
and just made a corpus.
This was back in the innocent days when
no one was paying attention to any of
this. So, this books corpus was around
for many years in the academic computer
academic community.
Um, since then it has been taken down
because it violated the terms of
service.
Okay? Just because it was free and you
can get it doesn't mean it's it was
legally allowed.
Um, so
one thing about to note about BERT is
that
the sequences were documents rather than
sentences. All the language modeling
research before that was focused on
sentences.
Okay, so in 2019 GPT-2 came around and
so what did they do?
Um, so they
wanted to get high quality web content.
And at that time people knew about
Common Crawl,
but somehow the Common Crawl data was
too messy.
So, what they did was came up with this
clever idea where you can take
you look at pages
that are outgoing links from Reddit
posts with
greater than three karma.
So, good posts must link to good good
good websites. So, you grab those
those
pages and you get 40 GB of
text, a million pages.
Um, they never released this data,
but there was an open replication of web
text
which people use quite a bit.
Um
Okay, so
so that's a GPT-2. So, as you're going
through this, I guess think about both
uh
you know, there's many methods of
filtering and collecting data and it's
interesting to look at these design
choices and
um okay, so CCNet was developed by um at
that time Facebook. Um so the goal was
to create large high-quality data sets
for pre-training and they were
interested especially interested in um
low-resource languages.
Um so they didn't want some very manual
process that only worked for for
English.
Um so they did did a bunch of things.
They did deduplication
um
and uh language identification. They
trained a classifier to detect a
language um and
keep the only the language that you
you're looking for.
Um and for quality filtering
uh the idea that they had was they
wanted to keep documents that look like
Wikipedia.
So Wikipedia
um at the time was deemed good
high-quality content and they use the
language model that was trained on
Wikipedia and you score probability of
a a new document under that language
model to gauge how Wikipedia-like it
was.
So rather than outgoing links to Reddit,
they use a language model on Wikipedia.
Um and uh they you know show that uh
because you can get much more more data,
you can actually outperform uh training
uh performing just training on Wikipedia
and this was a tool that will later uh
appear in some other papers.
So um
here is another work. This is from
Google uh 2019. Um
so this is called C4.
So this paper is actually more famous
for the T5 model um which pushes the
idea that you should just treat all the
NLP tasks in a world as text-to-text.
But actually a big contribution of this
paper, which is a very long report, was
the C4 data set.
And the observation, which was
very clear at that time,
was that Common Crawl is
mostly not useful for natural language.
Right? There is sort of this idea that
you had these small data sets, and they
were high-quality, and then all you had
Common Crawl, which was a mess. And any
attempt to train on Common Crawl just
led to to junk results. So, people were
thinking like, "How do I get a larger
but high-quality subset of Common
Crawl?"
So,
we saw the Reddit idea, we saw the the
Wikipedia-like language model idea.
C4 used a
different idea, and this is saying,
"Let's just define a bunch of rules."
Which turned out to be fairly effective.
So,
um
basically, they keep lines that end in
punctuation, have more than five words,
remove pages with fewer than three
sentences,
remove pages that contain any bad words.
Um
Uh
remove things like terms of use,
you know, boilerplate. Interestingly,
remove the curly brace, which, you know,
filters out a lot of code. So, they
weren't clearly at that time they
weren't thinking about code models.
Um and they filtered out anything that
was not
English.
Okay, so the end result is that you have
156 billion tokens. So, you know, 40
sorry, 800 gigabytes of text. So, this
is much larger than the GPT-2 data set,
which was only 40 gigabytes of text.
Uh
a bit later, there was some analysis
done in C4, which showed Here is the
websites that were represented. So, you
have a bunch of Wikipedia, patents was a
very common
thing.
Um they also released the web text like
document. They also used this idea of
links in Reddit posts
um and
uh
from Reddit posts with greater than uh
three karma and filtered through those
pages.
Um
so they were able to
get using this method 17 GB of text
using 12 um
Common Crawl dumps. Remember web text
was 40 GB,
which means that Common Crawl is is, you
know, maybe incomplete or uh doesn't
have everything because if it had
everything, you should be able to hit 40
GB. And
And they they showed that at that time
you could use this data and improve on a
bunch of NLP uh you know, benchmarks.
Okay, so we've seen using rules,
um
things that look like Wikipedia, Reddit
links.
And now uh let's talk about GPT-3.
So GPT-3, the data set was um they did
their they used Common Crawl, they did
their own processing. Um there is this
web text which was essentially the GPT-2
data set but expanded. Um notice that
there's some overlap. Common Crawl does
overlap with this, but this is a subset
of more targeted um distribution.
Um there is this
in the paper it's described as books one
and books two, which is um miss
internet-based books corpora. So this
remains a mystery exactly what it is. Um
and Wikipedia.
Okay, so
so the result was about 500, you know,
GB of of text, 400 billion tokens.
Um
and to do the Common Crawl uh
processing, they trained a quality
classifier to distinguish things they
determined deemed to be high quality
from the rest. And they did some fuzzy
deduplication because
um
you know,
web text and Common Crawl had uh dupes.
Okay, so this paper um
followed the idea of using a classifier
to just to train to do quality uh uh
classification.
So, after GPT-3 came out, this was I
think a big event and there were a
number of efforts to try to things in
the open. So, one of the initial efforts
was the the Pile, which is
um
uh a grassroots effort uh from Eleuther
AI, where they had a bunch of um people
in this Discord just jamming and
figuring out high-quality sources and
they came up with this uh list in the
end. And today this is still pretty
interesting and diverse. It has
uh you know, the Common Crawl, has
PubMed,
um this has this thing called Books 3,
which you know, we'll talk about,
Archive GitHub, which we talked about,
um
you know, Wikipedia, IRC, another books
corpus, uh philosophy papers, and so on.
Um
And so,
uh
you know, they included this Enron
emails data set. So, Enron went bust in
20 2002 and um all the emails were
released and this is one of the few
email data sets we have, um which is a
weird distribution I think for um email,
but that's that's what you get.
Um so, Project Gutenberg was uh so,
let's talk about books a little bit. Um
So, Project Gutenberg was uh started
um in 1971 and it only includes books
that received copyright clearance. Uh
So, mostly books in the public domain.
And
there's this packaging of Gutenberg into
PG-19, which is
Gutenberg's before 2019.
And which is I guess most of them
because for them to be in public domain,
you have to wait 75 years.
So, Books 3, which is
kind of this
interesting
data set that appeared in the pile. So,
this is
described actually as
you know, 200K books from a shadow
library called Bibliotek.
It concludes all books from your
favorite authors.
And at that time, again, 2020, no one
was paying attention. It just sat you
know, people used it to train models.
And since then, it has been taken down.
So, you cannot use or should not use
Books 3 anymore.
We'll come back to Books 3 again.
So, Stack Exchange
uh
you've probably used um
uh quite a bit. Although, I guess these
days maybe less so because of AI. Um
There's a bunch of user contributed
questions and answers starting 2008. And
um
You know, one thing that's it's
interesting about this data set is that
it's a sort of a Q&A format.
And this is quite close to kind of a
real
you know, application.
So, normally you think about
pre-training data as here's Wikipedia
articles, just like raw text.
Right? But some parts of the web are
actually look like
you know, supervised, like what you
would want to ask your language model.
So, you know, which I think maybe
helps the model learn certain types of
question answering behaviors.
So, not everything is like super
magically emergent. It's like, well,
this type of data does exist on the web.
Um
So, there's also
this data has metadata, which is like
the number of votes, which are useful
for filtering. And again, this this data
is uh
released in data dumps that allows you
to just download without crawling it.
Okay, so now in 2021,
there was another paper from DeepMind.
They trained a model called Gopher,
which
was
never released and actually was sort of
subsumed by Chinchilla.
Um
Um but the description of data, I think,
is actually really good. You should read
this paper because I think it's very
thorough in the way that they describe
the data processing.
Well, except for the parts where they
don't tell you what's in the data. Um
so, there's there's this thing created
this MassiveWeb,
and they had
you know, C4, which remember was the
data set that we looked at before from
Google.
Um they trained on books, news, GitHub,
and Wikipedia. They don't say anything
about how they they got that. Um
So, um for the MassiveWeb, they
kept English, deduped,
and their quality filtering was also
based on manual rules. And part of the
reason for this is that they had more
control over that. So, I think as you
can see,
um
there is a sort of this like
division between people who wanted to
use rules,
um
and people who wanted to use
classifiers. Um
So, they got, you know, a massive
as the name suggests, a massive amount
of uh text.
Um
but, you know, their model was only
trained on like a very small fraction of
this uh of this uh data set.
Um
Okay, so
in 2022,
uh Llama 1 came out. And the data set
here, this was actually a a very nice
paper in that it detailed their
data processing. So, this is probably
one of the
uh last uh non-open, fully open uh
models that actually talk about their
data processing.
So, they have Common Crawl processed
with CCNet, which you know
um
uh about. Um the classification though
was whether the page references
uh was a reference of Wikipedia, not
whether it is actually a Wikipedia
article.
Um so, the idea is that, well, maybe
Wikipedia articles are like too
stylized. And we know that Wikipedia
articles references a bunch of other
articles, which are presumably good. So,
let's call those the good uh websites.
Um they had uh you know, C4. Um they did
a bunch of processing on GitHub to get
permissive licenses,
uh Wikipedia. Um they trained on, you
know, Books 3
and Project Gutenberg. So, Books 3
really got them in a lot of uh trouble
because they're just announcing to world
that, "Hey, I trained on this data set."
And you look back, "Oh, this came from.
Where did it come from?" It came from
the pile. "Oh, it came from a shadow
library." So, um
you know, that's why people don't to
talk about their data anymore.
Uh so, they looked at archive
um and uh actually used the the LaTeX to
do the the processing, Stack Exchange,
and they got a 1.2 trillion tokens. They
didn't actually release this data set,
but they had enough of a description in
their processing that this was uh
reproduced by Together's Red Pajama uh
V1 um data set, which was then used in
other, you know, sources.
So, as you can see here, Red Pajama V1
initially also contained Books3, which
has now been kind of uh
you know, stripped out.
So, various uh decisions made by early
on about copyright actually influence
have a fairly uh big kind of watershed.
Okay, so let's talk about Refined Web.
So, this is um
a paper
uh
that
um tried to make a point that web data
is all you need.
Right? So, the web, in some sense, is
everything. And then we talked about all
these specialized sources like there's
GitHub and archive and and Stack
Exchange. And they said, "Well, what
happens if we just um stick with the
web?"
So, they did job of uh doing the
transformation from HTML to text. They
filtered um using the Gopher rules,
which is basically keep things that look
like English.
Um they explicitly at that time still
said, "Avoid ML-based filtering to avoid
uh biases.
I don't want to like find an overly
narrow subset of uh of the web."
Um they did some, you know,
deduplication, and they had 5 trillion
tokens. They released about 600 billion
of them.
Um so, the fine-web uh from Hugging Face
um was a replication of Refined Web, but
improved it. So, they took all the
Common Crawl dumps at that time,
did some filtering, um again using
manual rules um because to not inject
biases,
deduped, um did PI removal, and got, you
know, 15 trillion, you know, tokens. So,
you can see that the size of the data
these data sets um is growing
you know, quite a bit.
Um
and
um
so then there is this Dolma data set
from AI2 and this is um
a data set that includes their own
processing of Common Crawl, the Stack
which we'll talk about before, C4 which
you know about and a bunch of other
things. Um
And the the Reddit data set was from
this this project
called PushShift.
Um and at that time you could still get
this data and you can you know, train on
it
before things got locked down. Um AI2
has their own um
you know, crawl of academic papers so
called Semantic Scholar so they derive a
data set based on that.
Um so, let's look at their Common Crawl
processing.
So,
um they
use a language identification, they So,
this was model based but quality
filtering still avoid model
uh based filtering.
Um and then they remove toxicity using a
rules and a classifier.
Um
and they got 3 trillion tokens out of
that.
So, DCLAM I think was maybe a point
where this idea of model based quality
filtering started to really kind of
become the the the norm here.
Um so, DataComp they their initial
motivation was to define some sort of
pipeline so that people can try
different data methods um in a standard
way and show results. But I think the
main way that I think people use this is
just using their data set that they
released to train models and do other
things.
Um
So, they
uh
process Common Crawl to produce data on
pool. So, this is completely unfiltered.
And if you look at this this is this is
massive, 240 trillion you know, tokens.
Um this is probably more than
number of tokens that anyone really
trains on. But, a lot of this is fairly
uh low quality. So, then they have a
pipeline where all that gets you know,
filtered if you only keep and you know,
English.
Um you have some sort of rules to really
narrow it down. You do dedupe. And then
you do this model-based filtering.
And you end up with you know, something
that's 1.4%. And this is the data set
that um
we'll see actually works you know,
pretty well.
So, the model-based filtering and this
was
you know, s- kind of strangely good. So,
to train a classifier,
they took um
Open
or Hermes,
which is
essentially a instruction data that was
generated by uh GPT-4
and Eli5, which is a subreddit with uh
various questions and answers. So, this
is um let's see.
Like these are tied the type of
questions that are in Eli5.
Um
Okay. So, anyway, you get the idea.
So, it's it's kind of weird, but um
but somehow this this works. So, the
negative examples are anything from
Refined Web, which is remember it's just
like a uh
a very loosely filtered version of the
web. It's basically the web. And it got
3.8 trillion tokens.
Um they train a fast class classifier.
Think about this is a linear classifier.
Um and then they show that this um this
magical classifier quality classifier
outperforms um a bunch of you know other
things that they they tried.
Um
So, DCL M this became sort of a for a
while at least in the open community a
bit of a gold standard for quality
filtering.
Um let's move on to Nematron. So,
Nematron this is from Nvidia.
They said that well DCL M filters too
aggressively. It's
removing like most of the data.
Um and remember they only got
uh uh
I mean 3.8 trillion tokens, right?
Um
So, we need more tokens.
So, what do we do? We are going to
um
do something more
uh I guess elaborate.
We're going to prompt our existing model
to score find uh web documents based on
educational value. So, we're going to
prompt a language model and said is this
education or not? Create a bunch of
labels, train a fast text model.
So, that's one
um classifier. Another classifier is
just using the DCL M classifier.
So, we're going to use those uh
classifiers. We're also going to use
synthetic data. So, this is
probably the one of the
um
I don't know if it's a it's probably not
the first, but uh one of the the main
data sets that really lean into
synthetic data as a for pre-training. Um
So, they had for low quality data as
deemed by these classifiers, you use a
language model to rephrase it to make it
more
uh look like Wikipedia.
Um for high quality data, we use a
language model to generate various
tasks. For example, given a Wikipedia
article I can generate question answers
or I can generate like please summarize
this
document, um extract key information
from it and so on.
So they resulted in
data set that was six trillion tokens.
So this is quite a you know
substantially larger than DCLM.
Um
and just for kind of reference
this is still
kind of small by
some you know considerations. So Llama 3
was trained on 15 trillion tokens, Gwen
3 was trained on 36 trillion. Although
there is a sort of this
it's not clear how big these unique
tokens these are because when you look
at token counts in language model papers
some of it's like repeated. Like you do
multiple epochs, two epochs that's twice
the number of tokens.
So you have to be careful when you look
at those numbers.
And they show that this
the data set is you know better. Their
high quality subset
beats the previous data sets.
Okay, so
up until now [clears throat] we've seen
a bunch of different
methods for
filtering. I think all of these sort of
look
very kind of similar at some level. You
take a web crawl, you either decide I'm
going to use rules to filter or I'm
going to use a model. If I'm going to
use a model then I have to decide what
looks like good data and then try to
train a classifier and classify all my
documents and select. And there's a
seems to be a trade-off between you can
take a lot of common crawl. You can get
um
you know 240
you know trillion tokens if you want,
but that's probably going to be really
low quality. Or you can get like one
trillion tokens and there's sort of some
you know sweet spot in between.
Let me
talk about two final things.
So code and
going back to this question of
licensing.
So the stack is
a very nice project that was trying to
make a really good coding data set since
it was cleared by 2022 that coding was
going to be really kind of important.
So what they did in the initial version
is that they
clone you know 137
new repos. They kept the ones that were
permissively licensed,
removed example near duplicates and
resulted in you know one sorry 3
terabytes of code.
And then
in 2024 they had an update and here they
took more than the metadata like the
issues, comments and PRs
from GitHub, the repositories from the
software heritage which we talked about.
They also scraped documentation from
various websites by crawling them. They
did a bunch of processing. So in GitHub
repos you have binary files which you
probably don't want to train on. They
have malware, you get rid of that.
A lot of GitHub especially these PRs are
bots so you have to filter that. Dedupe,
do PI reduction.
There's a lot of pull requests and stuff
and they basically subsample to kind of
keep it representative and the data set
manageable.
They also did this thing which was I
thought was kind of nice which is that
there's many programming languages out
there. There's a lot of Python.
A lot of C
but low resources languages like Nim
which I hadn't even heard of. They're
not that
um
common. So what they do is they compile
this code and then into a low level
intermediate language, LLVM, which
everything like C compiler can compile
into this, and they've uh juxtaposed the
low-resource language and the
intermediate representation. So, then
the the
the language model can actually learn um
the mapping between the shared low-level
representation, which has a lot of data
on, and the thing that it does has less
data on.
Um and just for fun, you add in all the
other
you know, good stuff um that you can.
So, this is sort of Stack V2 is like
mostly code and then plus other things
that were used to train um their coding
models.
And um and one thing about uh pull
requests is that
their pull requests and all the metadata
is not by its nature uh linearized
sequence. So, there has to be some steps
to take into linearize it.
So, one important thing you have to side
is how much context to provide. So, for
example, uh event might just be I
changed one line of code. Right? And
that could just be one line, but
presumably to learn
that, you want to provide some context,
maybe a few lines around it, maybe the
entire file surrounding that diff. And
these are some design decisions that you
have to make for um for linearization.
And so, they at the end of the day, the
tokens that they train on look something
like this, where it's sort of this like
XML like structured data, where you have
like the PR um and then you have a bunch
of diffs um and then for comments, you
have basically the events of like a
comment was posted um what the review
state of that uh PR was, and so on and
so forth.
So, it's not just learning um how to
generate code, but also the software
development process around code.
Okay, so finally, I'll talk about uh
common pile.
So recall that almost all the data on
the internet is copyrighted.
Um some of it is permissively licensed.
Some of it is even in the public domain.
And while you can appeal to fair use and
say I'm going to train on it anyway.
Um this is not quite settled. Right? So
if you're very very risk-averse, then
you say um well, let's
Like if I don't know whether it is okay,
that's a no.
If you take that attitude, then that's
what uh Common Pile did. So can you
train a good model with only
permissively licensed um data?
Um
or rather how far you can you get.
So
this was a project that uh went and
scoured the the internet for all the
different types of data that it could
possibly find that was worth training
on, that was permissively licensed. It
includes um you know, Stack V2 and code.
Um
turns out that a lot of government
proceedings are actually uh
permissively, you know, uh licensed. Uh
wikis, um some
uh things on the on the web. Some news
sites are actually um permissively
licensed. Academic papers,
um online, you know, forums, things that
are in the public domain,
um educational resources and and so on.
So in the end there were 8 terabytes of
you know, data, which is actually pretty
good for permissively licensed uh data.
Um doing this project is actually much
harder than maybe it sounds at first
glance. It's not just simple as like,
oh, you look at the license and you're
like, oh, yep, Apache, a good or or CC,
a good.
Um there's some subtleties.
Um
first is license laundering.
So, people are kind of sloppy with
licenses. So, people might take some
copyright work and just, you know, put
it on a slap a CC BY on it. Anyone can
write this on the internet. It's kind of
hard to tell whether this is like a real
real or not.
Um
there's also this uh common practice
where, you know, for example, Doma is
um
is permissibly licensed. Remember, Doma
is the AI2 collection,
but collection licenses don't extend to
the individual works.
So, the collection is like
you know, is you
I mean, first of all, there's a question
where the collections are I think
collections can be copyright, but you
can I guess you can put a license on it.
Um anything. Um but the individual works
um are not
uh
necessarily if uh good. So, you can't
just look at data sets on Hugging Face
and you Many data sets on Hugging Face
you see they have a permissive license,
but if you dig deeper, it's actually not
um permissively licensed at the
individual level.
And they also made a decision to
uh forego training on any synthetic uh
data because training
um language models on synthetic
unlicensed data is is unclear.
So, probably it's going fine um
because um like technically these these
are like open way models with MIT
license. You can um
you know, do whatever uh you can use
them however you want, but um you know,
these language models were uh
presumably also trained on unlicensed
data, so it's a little bit of kind of
data laundering if you are really kind
of honest um here.
Um so,
so with this uh,
data, they compared with a bunch of, um,
other models, um, like the first LLaMA,
uh, MBT, um, and Qwen. And on a bunch of
benchmarks, they show that this
is not bad. I would say it's not nearly
as It's not as good as the Qwen, uh,
models, for sure, but it's, uh,
certainly outperforming the very
old kind of ver um,
This is like, you know, from 20
20 three, I guess. So, quite old models.
Um, so, I would say that the conclusion
here is that you can do reasonably, but
it's I think it's still, uh, pretty
tough to compete without, um, doing more
tokens. But, I don't think this is the
final word on it, and I think you can
probably eke more out of publicly
permissive licenses if you try.
Okay, so, to summarize this, uh, lecture
here.
So, maybe hopefully I now I've,
um, given you some appreciation that
data is a very rich topic. It's not that
data just falls from the sky, or you
just go on Hugging Face and you download
a data dataset. Um, data has to come
from somewhere, and there's also a
technical, but also social context in
which, uh, data comes.
Um,
you know, because at the top, there's
the internet is a bunch of live
services. Right? There's hack to has
someone has to do the work of producing
raw whether it be the website that gives
you dumps, or someone has to build a
crawler, or or something.
And then, you someone has to make a
decision of how to process it into
usable form,
um, filtering, transformation,
deduplication. All of these things have
an impact on the quality of your final,
uh, language model.
And notice that filtering is like
probably one of the most
kind of important things. How do you go
from 200 trillion tokens to
you know, less than
like 3 trillion tokens. I think that
obviously is a huge reduction, which
um I think merits a lot of attention.
Data is in some sense a key ingredient
that differentiates language models. A
lot of language models are
um roughly the same kind of transformer
architecture,
um
but you know, data is some depending on
um how you process it can make a pretty
big difference.
There's plenty of legal and ethical
issues around data, um more than I can
get into this lecture.
And also, this this process is very
messy.
Um unlike, you know, some of the other
parts of this class, where things are
maybe more based on kind of first
principles,
um
you know,
data processing is right now, at least,
a lot just based on kind of vibes. You
set up you define this classifier, you
define this rule, you set some
threshold.
Um so, there are many opportunities to
improve. So, as you do your assignment
four,
uh maybe think about whether there's uh
better ways to do this, and this could
be maybe a research direction.
Okay, so that's it for today. So, next
time I'll continue talking about data.
I'll do talk a bit about uh
post-training data and a bit more about
uh you know, filtering.